bruxelles durcit le ton avec ankara dans
le cadre du sommet de l'union européenne
les vingt-sept se sont mis d'accord dans
la nuit de jeudi à vendredi pour une
première phase de sanction qui pourrait
en appeler d'autres
les mesures décidées sont des sanctions
individuelles et des mesures
supplémentaires pourront être décidées
si la turquie poursuit ses actions
motif de ces sanctions les activités
turques en méditerranée orientale dans
des zones maritime disputée avec la
grèce un navire turquie à semer la
discorde en menant ces derniers mois des
recherches d'hydrocarbures cette
décision européenne suscite la colère du
président turc recep tayyip erdogan
alors que le navire en question à
regagner les côtes turques depuis près
de deux semaines estivales
c'est assez sage l'agenda de sanctions
imposées en raison d'objectifs
politiques et de fronde dans
l'irrationnel sont nuisibles pour tout
est parti si tu me présentera l'étude ça
n'apporte aucun avantage du profil frei
de ce une nouvelle peu réjouissante pour
une économie turque déjà en berne à
laquelle il faut ajouter les sanctions
américaines
conséquence d'un contentieux entre
washington et ankara à propos d'un
système de missiles russes acquis par la
turquie